bonsoir à tous merci pour votre présence
aujourd'hui alors comme on dit il ya une
première fois pour tous la première fois
c'est avec vous aujourd'hui je n'ai
jamais parlé dans du monde donc ça va
être une grande première
et ce avec en fond la petite répétition
à la maison notre petit garçon d'à peine
4 ans m'a dit tiens maman je te prête
mon doudou il va tenir change quand je
vous présente le petit renne voilà vont
donc aujourd'hui nous allons passer à
travers une question qui nous touche
tous pourquoi est il important de
consommer des produits du terroir
nous allons tâcher d'y répondre on passe
on parle justement de différentes
sources notamment du marché de la bière
aujourd'hui comme ça ça va vous
permettre de comprendre un peu plus
notre business aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de l'importance de consommer des
produits du terroir est également quel
va être l'impact de la consommation des
produits du terroir et régionaux pour
l'économie helvétique
dans un premier temps nous allons
commencer avec la bière industrielle
dont la bière industrielle comme le nom
l'indiqué elle est fabriqué en usine
ce qui veut dire il ya des grandes
lignes de fabrication il y a des grands
lignes de production des mises en
bouteille beaucoup d'employés et on les
retrouve partout dans le monde
c'est une bière qui aussi surmédiatisé
d'ailleurs les grandes entreprises
mettent beaucoup d'énergie dans le
marketing est d'ailleurs c'est vrai que
partout où vous allez vous allez vous
rendre compte que il ya une visibilité
ils sont vraiment connus par leur
visibilité et aussi que la qualité de la
bière qu'on peut consommer elle va ètre
identique
que vous soyez en suisse sont six
allemande en suisse romande que vous
soyez à l'étranger aux états unis où ou
en asie vous allez pouvoir découvrir le
même produit est le goût va être
standard ça va être la même chose
qu'elle soit est consommée en bouteille
ont pression ou bien dans les canettes
et c'est vrai que leur objectif c'est
vraiment de minimiser des coûts pour
être plus productif et bien entendu que
c'est une économie qui va rester
internationale et donc on va acheter ses
produits si pour donner de l'argent pour
les investisseurs contrairement la
brasserie artisanale
la dir est requise annales donc c'est
une bière qui est fabriqué par des
passionnés donc par exemple nous nous
avons commencé dans la
dans la cuisine du chalet à la maison on
a fait goûter justement notre bière à
nos amis et après on s'est dit bon c'est
juste extraordinaire c'est des produits
vraiment formidables c'est que c'est une
histoire qui est propre à chaque
brasseur chacun commence à sa manière
évolué et aussi ses des ingrédients
authentique parce que je pense que vous
savez pour faire de la bière
le produit principal ces lots dont klaus
est le produit le produit nécessaire
ensuite il faut des céréales maltais il
faut du houblon est de la levure
maintenant c'est vrai que si vous faites
la même recette et qu'elle ait fait que
ce soit on va aller dans les montagnes
que ce soit en pleine que ce soit au
tessin ou en suisse allemande la même
recette n'aura pas le même goût parce
que l'eau est différente
donc ce sont vraiment des ingrédients
qui sont authentiques et après c'est des
saveurs qui sortent de l'ordinaire
aussi on peut chaque brasseur va avoir
sa propre recette il va ya vraiment et
sa touche personnelle et du coup la
faveur va se dégager avec un goût qui
est vraiment particulier et qui pourra
le mettre en avant et c'est vrai que
c'est un breuvage qui s'apprécie pour
moi le la bière c'est un peu comme que
le mot comme le vin on le partage autour
d'une table avec des amis
c'est pas une bière où on va boire boire
boire on peut aussi bien entendu mais
c'est vrai que on va on va vraiment la
déguster vraiment comme comme du bon vin
et c'est vrai que après c'est une valeur
ajoutée pour une région pas c'est vrai
que le consommateur va s'identifier soit
par des montagnes soit par un lac soit
par un nom soit part parce qu'il connaît
le producteur il va s'identifier
il va être heureux et va être fiers donc
il pourra la consommer avec encore plus
de plaisir et après c'est une économie
qui va rester local également alors
voilà maintenant je vais passer la
parole à robbie qui va vous parler du
marché en général pour la bière merci
très bien voici pendant cette première
présentation présentation on s'est dit
on n'était pas trop créative avec notre
pari pointe à mon ami tu notre
créativité dans les biens dont on n'y
était pas et puis on est en plus ça
tombe bien le thème de cette soir parce
que quand on a proposé de poser une
question ces dix mois qu'on est un peu à
un peu crue d'un pub brusque avec les
produits
le produit de masse de grands
producteurs de bien mais c'est difficile
de mettre les poings faut se dire qu'on
est m de soirée c'est des produits de
terroir parce qu'on sait tout cela
on est tous là parce que ça nous
intéresse les produits du terroir elle a
posé ses les produits de masse donc ça
va peut-être sommes dans pure négative
quand les gosses mais c'est pas faux
c'est pas on n'a pas fait exprès c'est
juste s'asseoir comme ça et puis je vous
promets qu'ils ont pas ils n'ont pas
peur de nous parce qu' entre ces quatre
là c'est 4 contre docteur etienne la
moitié du marché de la bière dans le
monde entier
50% de biens consommés par nouveau les
fabriquer par ces quatre groupes
d'acteurs donc nous va dans la prochaine
en suisse on tient du végal 3% du marché
donc il ne voit pas pas encore
ce qui est ce que je veux je voudrais
vous proposer ce soir vous gé je
voudrais expliquer ces deux le fait
qu'aujourd'hui il tient la moitié du
marché
ils ont tous deux multinationales qu'ils
ont les investisseurs derrière qui
cherchent chaque année plus d'argent
plus de rendre de rendement sur
investissement est la fête qui peut être
entre 4 et 6% du marché par année ça va
dire que il doit chercher ailleurs pour
retrouver de nouveaux clients et
aujourd'hui 7 milliards c'est la chine
qui perdent entre 4 et 6% de marché dans
le monde entier mary cooper contre 20 et
28 % pendant la chine
si on est on est on se met dans les
chaussures de consommateurs on a déjà
une histoire de cardinal à fribourg et
on a des investisseurs qui nous donner
l'argent pour agrandie de marché qu'est
ce qu'on va faire ce qu'on va réinvestir
dans la suisse dont europe aux etats
unis en chine où on peut attirer entre
20 et 25% des marchés par année donc
c'est clair
l'agent va d'investissement va aller
ailleurs et ça ça tombe bien pour nous
parce que on est petit on est en suisse
la plante des avantages de petit
producteur et ça nous laisse la place
en plus en suisse vous savez tous les
soirs de kaysersberg un cardinal s'cusez
moi je connais pas trop j'étais pas là
ces moments là mais c'est que la fensch
la scène tient tinée détient excuses
manque important de marché suisse il
faut y font partie des 15 berg et ses 15
buts qu'ils ont acheté cardinal donc on
voit déjà l'évolution de cette 7ème
plus comme je disais avant buvait que 3%
de marché suisse est signé par le bio
artisanal et chaque année on prend de
plus en plus on conseille très bien
depuis une année
si on compare l'hiver dernier l'hiver
qui ont bien défini on a doublé la
production mais c'est d'ouvrir trois
poissons et sap a beaucoup bougé
il ya toujours de la place il ya encore
de la place
l'importance cela liberati zonal de
produits du terroir vous voulez c'est
comme vous avez entendu on a entendu
parler la suisse la fiat et de la suisse
vous êtes fia vous cherchez vous avez un
profond pour les produits suisses
la route produit que des chocolats des
fromages mais vous avez une préférence
pour ces produits
en plus je trouve assez soit c'était un
joli étude de marché c'est soit parce
que aujourd'hui on a la bière artisanale
et des mojitos et apparemment de
tendance
aujourd'hui ces deux des bois - de bien
des masses et puis juste de des boissons
avec la côte fois elle est baptisée
projet bien emporter donc ça tombe bien
c'est sans confirmation de notre tirer
des affichages ce qui a été fait et puis
en plus la fête que nous sommes petit on
a un petit quantité tous les
microbrasseurs il s'appelait
microbrasseurs parce qu'ils ont vraiment
petit
on est aussi agile au praj réagit on
peut faire un nouveau bien on peut de
sortie on peut les vendre
si ça marche génial on continue si ça
marche pas enfin un autre on est très
dynamique on peut changer un peu à
évoluer
on peut en plus écouté les clients pour
réagir mais les gosses ils ont une bière
ça passe partout ça va pas changer ça
peut pas changer parce que ça doit
passer par tous
excuse moi est le point le plus
important pour moi c'est soit c'est le
point qu on a mis en mode et je vais le
lire pour être sûr que c'est juste c'est
l'argent qui est dépensé sur les
produits locaux
les deux fois plus efficace pour
l'économie locale
si vous n'avez pas déjà sont et un petit
accent je suis américain ne s'est pas
dit si je viens du des états unis de 15
as avec 8 millions d habitants qu'on a
suisses c'est un des plus petits pays
aux etats unis le marché suisse marché
artisanal le produit donc génial parce
que pour moi au 15 aces pour aller
chercher de fromage il faut faire 5 me
qui démontre ici je peux faire à trois
kilomètres et puis j'ai trouvé ma voisin
qui fait du fromage et ça c'est un point
très fort pour la suisse
les tailles et puis en plus les verriers
variété de produits
et puis le parti positive par an la
suisse et le produit local artisanal
c'est le l'économie et plus du fou de
l'argent est deux fois plus efficace son
produit local ça reste dans la région ça
soit pas de norvège pour réveiller un an
plus tard ça reste dans leur région ça
reste dans notre poche
et ça c'est très important en plus
le producteur fait partie du menu
communauté
ça peut être aussi nagat et si j'ai fait
une bière qui est quelqu'un d ism pas
trop à la crèche j'ai beaucoup de
commentaires le matin pour finir cette
petite discussion on voulait mettre côte
à côte le produit local des produits
produits internationale on sait très
bien c'est à vous de choisir sial
consommateurs de choisir mais on venait
quand même être côte à côte pour voir si
ça vous intéresse
donc effectivement par rapport au
produit local s'est fabriqué pour une
consommation rapide donc on le fabrique
en levant et le consommateur peut
l'acquérir elle dégustait tout de suite
il faut deux micros le produit
internationaux fait de bien des masses
le la gare effet pourrait transporter il
faut le garder du mois avant qu'on ne
consomme la bière artisanale
on peut la consommer après trois
semaines mais les produits
internationale pour les grosses
producteurs y fait un produit qui est
beau quant au bois pendant des mois mais
voilà le produit local c'est une
exclusivité vous allez pas retrouvé le
même produit chez le brasseur voisins
que le brasseur vous avez envie de vous
servir c'est vraiment une exclusivité
c'est une histoire pour moi commencer
juste l'amo les goûts et des même nom
partout dans le monde mais ça change pas
après voilà la valeur ajoutée reste dans
la région par rapport à effectivement
quand on va acheté au magasin
donc on va payer et le magasin va
pouvoir payer le producteur et voilà
l'argent va circuler
régionalement localement et de grandes
boîtes
ils gagnent leur argent par les
investisseurs c'est pas pour nous c'est
pour les autres
et puis voilà pour la livraison aussi
mais on économise aussi on va plutôt ne
pas dépenser trop d'argent sur les
livraisons
parce qu'on reste dans un produit d'un
rayon locale donc une économie de
l'énergie
encore une fois de négoce avec 1go ce
voyou mais il faut un gros sa chaîne de
produits et puis les grosses
camionnettes pour l'ivresse et c'est un
enfant stocks assez intéressant aussi il
ya un contact de proximité donc ça veut
dire que le consommateur va connaître
son producteur ou bien on vide le
connaître aussi s'il a des remarques des
questions le producteur est toujours là
et c'est toujours important d'avoir ce
contact de proximité est le produit de
masse et customiser ans fonctionne de
marketing le produit ne change pas c'est
juste le des images qu'on voit alors
maintenant une question se pose
ça va arriver finalement pourquoi est il
important de consommer des produits
régionaux locaux du terroir et surtout
se soucier de tout ce qu'on a pu
entendre jusqu'à maintenant vous allez
le savoir ça arrive
voilà alors surtout déjà afin de faire
que marcher l'économie locale helvétique
ce qui est avant tout important de
favoriser les petits producteurs ce qui
met de l'énergie qui met du coeur
justement fournir des des produits de
qualité vous retrouvez aussi des goûts
et des saveurs uniques que vous allez
par trouver ailleurs
et aussi pour consommer des produits
exclusifs et de qualité donc en fait la
phrase finale à tout ça c'est vrai que
le consommateur c'est à dire vous c'est
à dire nous on a tous le droit d'être
égoïste et surtout de faire ses choix
merci beaucoup